hi everyone and thank you for joining us
today
we're here to talk about critical design
considerations
for rapid diagnostic tests in a
covered 19 pandemic so we we're joined
by
a group of panel guests so in no
particular order we've got brendan
o'farrell
the president and co-founder of tcn
diagnostics
we've got davon rolls who's the
president and ceo of sona nanotech
klaus hockleiner who's our technical
specialist at sativa
and david wilson who's the commercial
director at avacta
the format of today's call is we're
going to have a discussion around
three points so understanding the
different
technologies available moving on to why
a dual approach between those different
technologies is the best approach
and then spend some time around the
different design
challenges that people will face when
developing natural flow tests and what
support exists to help developers
so to start brendan would you like to
help explain the different technologies
available
sure thing thanks lee um so
i guess the you know the methods for for
testing
uh relatives to seroscope to infection
really break down
broadly i suppose into into molecular
versus immunoassay
so molecular tests we're looking for
obviously the molecular material of the
virus
you know in the case of steroid b2
that's rna so the primary method used is
rt-pcr
and that starts by converting the viral
rna into dna and then amplifying it
using pcr to a level of which it can be
detected so several
other isothermal amplification methods
obviously are being
developed and implemented as well so the
main advantage of rtpcr in this context
is the relative speed of the assay and
the fact
that it can be automated and high
throughput and it can be very sensitive
and specific if it's developed
correctly so uh but obviously rtpcr has
its
limitations as well uh the primary
sample used for detecting stars kobe 2
is a nasopharyngeal swab
and those are difficult to collect
effectively and they're really
uncomfortable for the patient
taking them also potentially exposes the
health care worker
taking the sample to infection which has
pushed us in the direction of a lot of
thoughts around self-sampling
other sample types like nasal swabs and
tongue swabs are being evaluated and
implemented
but they obviously come with their own
challenges as well uh particularly when
it comes to the performance of the assay
so traditional rt pcr requires a lot of
lab infrastructure a lot of equipment
trained users and these tests are most
commonly done
at scale in in central or hospital labs
as a result
so more recently we've seen some small
instruments developed that can be
deployed to more decentralized testing
environments
and these have the advantage of a lot
more portability but obviously they're
complex instruments
for the most part still requiring
trained operators and at least some
infrastructure and maintenance so it is
also the
primary issue i suppose of access time
to delivery of results and scale
and turnaround time right now on
centralized rgptr
assays from sample to results is on the
order of multiple days
uh even in the best of circumstances so
processing of of cover 19 samples also
requires
by containment labs operated by highly
trained technicians obviously
and for more resource limited countries
with less access
to central laboratory resources and less
capacity
than the developed nations this kind of
central lab testing
at the required scale really isn't an
option um
so the alternative approach is
immunoassay and with this format
we're detecting the presence of specific
proteins
in a sample that are indicative of
current or previous infection
and these assays can either be
instrument based and run in a central
lab but they can be run at the point of
care as a rapid assay
the most ubiquitous format of rapid
assay being the lateral flow format of
course that
most people are familiar with in the
context of pregnancy testing or
hiv testing or strep throat testing at
the at the doctor's office
but has been applied as a very mature
technology
in literally hundreds of applications
over the course of the last 30 years or
so
so there are two primary applications of
of the immunoassay in the context
of the pandemic i suppose is antigen
detection and antibody detection
there's a lot of different use cases
around each type but in broad strokes
you know the antigen detection uh
indicates the presence of
viral proteins in the sample once again
typically the nasopharyngeal swab
in the current embodiment and the
presence of these
protein antigens like the spike protein
is
indicative of infection with the virus
so the value of the antigen testing
uh probably self evidence you know if a
swab taken from a patient test positive
they're infected and likely infectious
uh
on the the serological assay or the
antibody detection assays
these use binding reagents to detect the
presence of antibodies directed against
the specific viral antigens
so typically we're looking at uh igg and
igm
although there's growing evidence that
iga has has utility in the context of
cobot
so stereological assays are useful
because a patient that's recovered from
covert 19
um once the virus is cleared from the
body the viral rna
is no longer available for detection in
the respiratory tract so
there's really pretty short window
during the acute stage of infection
in which cytoskeleb2 can be detected
using pcr
or immunoassay for viral antigen
detection so while the pcr or antigen
detection by immunoassay works well
for diagnosis of ongoing infection it
doesn't give a clear indication
of whether a patient has been infected
historically and
potentially and i would put a lot of
emphasis on the word potentially
what their immune status might be i'm
sure we'll come back to that
uh but antibody tests have their
limitations too um
though data is still emerg emerging it
appears that the the antibody response
to covert 19 is slow compared
to a lot of other infections and with
limited data it appears that
the initial igm antibody response
doesn't peak until about nine days after
infection and the igg response
uh is several days after that and to put
this into perspective most viruses would
elicit a primary immune response within
about five days of infection
now because of this stars kobe 2
antibodies
are unlikely to make good uh markers of
acute coca 19 infection
so you know as a result the detection of
antibody alone for acute phase diagnosis
is really viable and and the topic of
whether a total antibody test is the
ideal specification
rather than one that differentiates igg
and igm is being
pretty highly debated in places while
antibodies
you know might not be appropriate for
acute phase diagnosis they still show a
lot of valuable applications
uh in the context of covert 19. so
potentially the most valuable use
of wide-scale antibody testing is as a
public health tool
you know indicating levels of exposure
to the virus there's lots of talk about
using these assays to indicate immune
status but the science
is still largely out on whether that's a
valuable use case for a lot of these
tests
but today i'm aware of at least 12
different identified use cases
for serology assets a lot of which
required
somewhat different assay specifications
so how to use these assays and develop
them is going to be
a hot topic for some time to come so
hopefully that outlines the the basic
framework
lots of details and nuance in there to
be debated and discussed
but uh i'll hand back at that yeah no
thanks brenda that's brilliant
so i guess you know from that
explanation close are you able to help
explain how
i guess we're using both of the
molecular and amino acid approach
in the real world to tackle this
well the point was the molecular
diagnostic test was that
um these were the first tests that have
been developed because people quickly
sequenced the virus are created primers
and were able to detect the
virus in patient samples as brandon
already
pointed out that's something that needs
to be done in a centralized lab
uh it's something where you need an
infrastructure train people you have to
ship the samples to the lab and it takes
ages
before you get the result back to the
patient and that means in that time yeah
you either have to guarantee the patient
uh or
the patient will spread the virus to
other people
um the development of
tests for antigens for viral antigens is
ongoing
so first test on the market was limited
sensitivity but the original idea
is to have a test that identifies
the patient as positive
let's say in a doctor's office um
and is then confirmed by a molecular
diagnostic test in essential laboratory
so that would be a two-step approach um
and that should avoid
um at least false positives the risk is
false negatives
and the tests that are currently on the
market the best one has a sensitivity of
eighty percent
uh that means of uh ten people that are
really
real positives that you test you will
miss two
um and that means at the moment as a
stand-alone test
uh it's not yet feasible and this is
what people are working on
uh what makes your life an additional
misery is
that um that there are four endemic
human coronaviruses that cause 10 to 15
percent
uh of human common colds uh these
viruses are all closer
related so you have a fair chance of
getting positive signals that are from a
biological
biologist's point of view real positive
signals
um and unfortunately you detect the
wrong virus
um things will get worse when we talk
about antibody tests
the first problem is that in a typical
study what you see is that the first
igms
appear on day five of the onset of
symptoms
and then you have forty to fifty percent
of the patients
uh developing the antibodies um
you will have igms in all patients
around day nine or ten
uh which makes that as brandon already
said a no goal for
finding acute phase diagnostics and
uh what is even more interesting is that
um antibodies against different
coronaviruses cross-react
uh this has been uh published for zazz
kobe one
um and uh antibodies against the endemic
human coronaviruses
we know it for the merc uh coronaviruses
it's the same story and it goes
it goes in both directions and there is
absolutely no reason to believe
uh that this will be by any means
different for saskov2
um and that means if you go for antibody
tests you have
a very high chance to get
an awful lot of false positives that
means uh you will run into trouble with
your epidemiological statistics
at the end it means we need to develop
more accurate tests
for the antigen in order to
help diagnose our corbit 19
in under-resourced regions uh and even
in in what we call first world countries
in um in a near patient situation in a
doctor's office
um and then confirmed that by a pcr test
what i do not buy and to be honest is
the idea to have self-sampling
self-sampling regardless whether you use
another pharyngeal
samples or saliva samples has a very
good chance
um to fail due to our user errors
um and that makes them very difficult
um as a as a screening test
and this is what we're looking for and
um that
means i would always opt for a test that
why the sampling is being done by a
trained person
which leads us back to the doctor's
office
so that's for the approach that is uh
that is currently being used so do an
immological
antigen test first um and then do a
confirmatory test
uh for the positive tested people
um we have to develop antigen tests that
have
a sensitivity that's much better than 95
percent
uh else it will not be useful for a
screening test
and the antibody test that we are
talking about will not involve a
two-step approach
uh but they have a fair chance to give
you false positives due to crossroad
activities was the endemic human
coronavirus antibodies
um and um again
this needs to have a very high
sensitivity and specificity
in order to be useful as a screening
tool
to talk about um
immunity and the population whatever
that means
and nobody knows how long it will last
the problem is we know from all other
coronaviruses it doesn't last forever
and again there is no reason to believe
that this will be the case
that this will not be the case for this
new coronavirus
okay thank you yeah we will need to test
for a very long period of time
yeah okay now if i get close i think
that uh
you said quite a good picture of how
complicated this is to
get something with the required level of
sensitivity and accuracy that we need
which i know you touched on a few
different areas there you know such as
sample collection and
other pieces but maybe david you can
help um
start the conversation around some of
the design considerations and
some of the challenges that um typically
you've encountered
during the development um yes so out of
acta
we we've been focused on the development
of a uh
antigen test on a lateral flow
platform and recently announced our
collaboration with sativa
to develop that particular test
the aim is is to develop a test that can
be easily deployed
in a community primary care and
a uh you know a consumer setting
we believe the lateral flow format is is
the
really the only format that we're aware
of that will enable
the mass testing or mass population
screening that's going to be required
in order to get society back to normal
whatever normal will be
and there is a lot of demand for this
type of testing
outside the traditional healthcare
settings
one of the biggest opportunities is to
enable workforce testing for example
to get workers back into into companies
um
uh to get you know sporting events
back uh concerts uh public transport
um so there's a there's there's a huge
demand so we've been focused on
the development of a test which will
enable that to happen
um so that that's good that requires a
what we think is a lateral flow uh
format and
uh saliva as a sample as opposed to the
nasopharyngeal swabs
so um some of the the challenges well
one of them is
time um you know typically these tests
take you know many months uh you know 18
months
18 to 24 months to develop we don't have
the luxury
of that at the moment and so
uh all companies i know that are
developing
these and other coffee 19 tests are
trying to do it in a way that's
different from how it's normally done in
order to accelerate
the time to market and and clearly that
introduces um
you know a a somewhat risk um
but uh you know we can't we don't have
the luxury of
18 to 24 months to to get these these
products out
so that's um that's one uh very big
challenge
also the access to
clinical samples you know they are in
high demand and short supply um
increasingly so as the
as the pandemic starts to um
disappear although i agree with klaus's
earlier comments that they need for
testing
and the demand for testing is not going
to go away for a very long time
you know we anticipate that there will
be a need for testing
you know in in very significant numbers
for at least another 12 months
so time is a challenge um and
the develop a
test that can be deployed in these
settings is also
one of the biggest challenges for a
diagnostic test developer
because of the the need to develop a
test that can be used
easily by a consumer for example
for a self-test so that's a challenge
it's also a challenge from the
regulatory approval process
um you know typically the regulatory
approval for these tests
um and the clinical validation study
needs are
are significant so again
the uh authorities the fda
for example the mhra in the uk
um are looking at ways to provide
accelerated approval processes for these
tests so we can enable them to get to
market otherwise again
they won't be coming to market in time
to enable us to fight this
this pandemic so there are a lot of
challenges associated with the fact that
we're trying to get something
to market um much much more quickly than
than than we would traditionally do as a
as a diagnostic
product manufacturing company and and to
be honest our
are you know probably more comfortable
um
doing with the the more standard
timelines um
but um you know we these these tools are
absolutely required without them
uh it's going to be much more difficult
for us to um
to get society back back to normal so
there's uh
and then on top of the all of this
there's supply chain issues i mean i'm
outlining lots of problems
um but they're they're really just to
introduce maybe topics of conversation
for the rest of the
the the webinar um because of the the
demand
for for these for these tests the supply
is under
a lot of strain and that's the supply
not just the tests themselves but all
the components
and raw materials and that's an issue
which needs to be addressed because the
supply chain needs to be ramped up um
again in a in a time scale which it's
never been done
before
so yeah it's it's uh
it's just an outline of some of the the
major the major
hurdles and and challenges that we're
we're facing at the moment to get these
products to market
okay thanks david darwin to say anything
you'd like to elaborate upon what uh
david's added or anything you didn't
produce from your side
well yeah thankfully um well as
david outlined you know i think uh you
can everybody
listening to this can probably get a
sense of the enormous challenge that
uh anybody that's developing one of
these tests is up against uh for sure
um and and it is it does come down to
time constraints
um you know that's a major thing um you
know david outlined
you know all the problems that we're
seeing um
you know so i'm not gonna kind of dwell
on those you know
they'll be discussed as we go through
this presentation i think one of the
one of the major things that um you know
sonar
has come up against with regards to
challenges um
in terms of our biggest hurdle is
probably that
um you know access to some of those
materials um you know
it being everything from test component
materials
all the way through you know to some of
the specific biological materials that
you need to get
uh to be utilized um you know similarly
back the test
um so this test has been based around
the ice antigen-based tests
um you know we initially were focusing
on the nasopharyngeal swab
uh type systems um but uh our
our platform and our process is easily
adaptable to other matrices
including uh you know saliva as well uh
but
uh our first person after his priority
really is to
um you know kind of see a critical path
to developing a test
uh utilizing um a nasopharyngeal swab
and so it's alongside all the other kind
of constraints that david's
kind of outlined around you know time
regulatory clinical
pathway um access to materials etc
uh you know i think we echo one another
and um
you know and we've spoken um you know
offline around these things many times
um one of the other major things uh
probably
at least going to be a challenge which
is we're certainly a topic of discussion
that david just touched on is the
infrastructure around
um you know the development of rapid
tests now typically
you know lateral flow tests hundreds and
hundreds of millions of these tests
um you know produced every year across a
plethora of different disease states and
for many other use case scenarios but
they typically
there's probably maybe a handful or two
of core material suppliers for things
like membranes
and pads and antibodies even
but then also machinery to produce these
tests you know there's
unless you're unless you have a
significant production set up in-house
which obviously some of the major
players
do but everybody else doesn't then they
utilize
um you know cmos that are out there
contract manufacturing organizations and
again there's typically a handful of
those um that
you know obviously we're in discussions
with multiple uh groups around that and
um
you know one of those challenges is
about around uh
beyond the test development process
itself uh you then typically would go
through a tech transfer process
uh which again normally uh we talk about
normal versus expedited time frames
that our process is normally a six month
process in itself
um and we're asking those cmos to pretty
much rip up the rule book
um you know but but still make sure that
they're doing to those quality systems
to make sure
products that are transferred are done
so correctly
and then produced at the scale of
manufacture that is expected because
um you know as we know the the mass
screening that's required here
uh that's uh expected uh to ramp up
production from even even from a few
million tests to hundreds of millions of
tests which is what we all anticipate
that's needed
and you know it's a huge task on not
just us as test developers
but also all the manufacturing
organizations as well and those typical
those manufacturing organizations are
typically serviced by
again a handful of companies that you
know produce the manufactured equipment
um
so it's a you know as a diagnostic india
as a whole
everybody that's in this tight network
i've all
recognized the challenges we've all kind
of um everybody's come together
uh very very quickly you know what we're
once seen as competitors are now
certainly collaborators um everybody's
working hard together to kind of
uh you know allow each other to bring
those tests to market because
everybody can see the need uh you know
for that
so supposedly just to pick up a little
on the on the topic of development
challenges you know the
dcn diagnostics is a contract developer
of lateral flow
assays this is what we that's what we do
for 11 is what we've done for for
several decades now and
um you know so we're we're used to
dealing with the with the with the
typical challenges right
that everybody in the industry is aware
of you know
starting from the concepts of designing
really usable tests for point of care
application which covers everything from
getting the right sample
to getting the test to run correctly to
making sure it can be interpreted
correctly
digitally or by eye to the analytical
challenges
of just making the system work selecting
the right reagents getting the right
materials ensure that
everything as as as as darren and david
said
what goes through the correct process
and goes through it correctly
ultimately ending up in a properly
validated product that can then be
scaled and manufactured
right um so all of those challenges
still exist here but let's say we're
you know obviously we're trying to
compress this timeline
and and we're doing it based on a on a
real
risk benefit analysis right so there's
there is risk
to this kind of acceleration and the
reason we go through that usual process
of developments is to end up with a
really robust
reproducible product that can be scaled
right
and as darren points out that that
scaling and that manufacturing requires
a
very very specific and quite limited
skill set
um so one thing that in this whole
process that can't be clawed back you
know obviously the development happens
on a continuum so we can draw the lines
anywhere in the process to say
we've reached a point where we're happy
to release this product to market we've
reached a point where we're happy to
submit this to
a regulatory authority under an
emergency youth or authorization
or whatever the case may be but what we
can't claw back in that process is time
right so we are drawing a line in that
development process at a point where we
haven't by definition
under any circumstances demonstrated
that our products are
highly reproducible and highly scalable
at the level at which we're going to
have to manufacture them so there's
inherent risk in that process
so what we have to do as development
organizations and manufacturing
organizations is try to pull back as
much of that risk as we can
through you know the still the proper
application of development methodologies
and understanding that even after we
have released these products to market
in this specific instance
uh development continues right this is
this is not a there's not a defined line
here that says this product is gone
um it's the exact opposite in fact you
know from
every level of this process the fact
that the target product profiles
are still shifting both for antigen and
for antibodies so we actually don't
really have a great idea of what the
final product has to be we're making
some very
well educated guesses um
but that's that's going to change so the
target product profile is going to
change
the performance requirements are going
to change our understanding of the
process is going to change
our experience with these processes is
going to change over time
so this is going to be very much an
evolutionary process um
and and one of the things when we're
talking about supply chain that that
that we see as
i i guess one of the bigger risks
certainly we all understand the reagent
supply issues
we understand the material supply issues
we understand the you know the
manufacturing equipment side of things
one of the biggest gaps we see in the
market and
is is knowledge and it's in its
education you know a lot a lot of
companies have been forced into a
position where they're having to scale
manufacturing processes really quickly
uh they're having to do so with with
people who may not have the experience
level that that we'd like to see
you know in these processes and again
there's a there's a risk benefit being
done here
we need these products but but i
certainly wouldn't
skip over the the question of the
knowledge gap that's in this market
right now we need
we need more trained people we need more
experienced people
and that's unfortunately not something
that's going to happen quickly but it's
something that we need to work on too
no i think it's very good and one of the
things
so one of the things that works in a
while i know that um you touched it very
briefly earlier was about uh
the importance of time to market sorry
the time to test
and i'm getting a quick result on these
which you know it's
critical that um we have a instant
result where the current bottleneck is
taking several days sometimes for
results
so to help expand on that piece that you
mentioned earlier brendan
sorry you actually broke up on me there
just a little bit so the questions
yeah when we were talking about the
different technologies and you
introduced arts um you've seen that
lateral flow
the importance of this is you know
getting a quick result
and i guess you know just some of the
challenges around that i guess in
what you're saying about the less
reproducibility and that you're able to
go for at the moment
well you know the the time to results
obviously in the context of the testing
that we're doing time to result is
critical right so
um one of the benefits of lateral flow
technology
you know as a platform is that allows us
to take a sample do the test on the spot
and have a result within
minutes um now we can couple that
obviously with reading technologies as
well whether they're you know within the
cassette whether they're external
readers
um and do instantaneous data gathering
databasing
we can have all of that data available
in real time as well so
there's obvious benefits to that in the
context particularly of antigen testing
where we're trying to get
to a decision as to whether somebody has
an active infection really quickly
get them into quarantine take whatever
uh measures need to be taken to ensure
their health and safety and
that of the people around them um
and so so having that instantaneous or
virtually instantaneous results is a
really really huge benefit
um now in the context of you know mass
population screening
uh you know particularly in the us you
know the us
has growing uh capacity for
centralized laboratory testing where we
can take those samples turnaround times
will improve but we're still talking
about
probably days from sample collection to
delivery of that result so
in the context of antigen testing that
still introduces a gap where there's
where there's significant risk um now in
the context of antibody testing where we
have so many potential use cases that
people are looking at and some of them
do require that instantaneous results
right so
some of the back to work testing or you
know testing of healthcare providers or
whatever the case may be we need that
results right and and this
that both from a serology and an antigen
perspective i think the lateral flow
platform
provides probably the only available
solution um
so it's uh you know it's it's it's
really ideally suited to this
uh in in many many ways
okay thank you to the technology that
that that's correct the problem my
problem is that
we need specificities and sensitivities
on an extremely large scale that is
definitely unprecedented uh simply due
to the fact that's a massive screening
and this has never been done before uh
in all electric flow tests that we have
on the market
you'll have patients that show the
symptoms um
and yeah if you want to test what we
want to do now
as we would like to test people that
have no symptoms
we have the slightest idea whether they
haven't they have or had an infection
and we need a test that gives us an
actual result
um on answers to these questions
and uh that's a completely different
piece and
the second problem is this this virus is
a new virus and that means it's a
rapidly moving target
uh currently i'm seeing about 50 papers
at least per week published on on
pre-print service
so you can't read them all and
but by the knowledge that that is
gathered and the surprises that
uh that are appearing as as really
astounding
and we as as test developers or material
developers or reagent developers
have to try to take place with it and
that that's a real challenge
and from an algorithmic perspective you
know one of the biggest differences here
is that we're talking about utilizing
a serology test in a way that it's not
normally used right so
serology tests are usually reflexed to
some kind of an orthogonal message for
come from our method for confirmation
right depending on
you know the the the endemicity of the
environment they're used in so
uh in this case we may not have that
safety net so
it's different yeah it's different
there's absolutely no safety now
yeah i think the the sensitivity issue
clause that you brought up and we've had
numerous conversations about this over
the past two weeks
um as you say i think it's uh it's a
major challenge
uh you know for for anybody developing a
test trying to get that sensitivity
level
down um you know i think we've discussed
whether you need to get viral
load readings down to you know the ten
to the two ten to the three level
um you know just to get a sense of the
limit of detection of these tests
and if not lower um you know to detect
you know bible loads in patients
um because i say that differentiation
between symptomatic or presymptomatic
patients and asymptomatic patients
um is a mass difference you know when it
comes to screening because
i think uh you know present even
pre-symptomatic patients um you know
it's hard for them to get a test in many
countries um you know that certainly
don't have
huge capacity for centralized lab
testing um you know so i think
screening tests like uh you know the
ones that we're trying to that we're all
trying to
develop here and whether it be antigen
or antibody based
um you know certainly have the role to
play in it and as we've alluded to
before that risk
benefit you know kind of trade-off is
the main key thing
but again coming back to the some of
those technical challenges the
sensitivity is going to be the one
the major issue and there is that
specificity issue around that
cross-reactivity
interference um you know whether the
existing kind of
thought-based uh viruses that are
floating around in the environment
so um again beyond you know
supply chain organizational issues
there's actual technical issues that
simply need to be overcome uh you know
by everybody as well
and they chose their own challenges but
i think uh
you know the world and certainly our
space that's full of smart scientists
and we're all working hard to overcome
those
issues and i think we're you know i'm
sure
together we'll all be able to uh you
know do so
uh yeah that's right i think specificity
is something that
many people overlook at that point uh
let's assume you have
uh five percent of of
uh the population or with an active
infection
um that may or may not show
symptoms so that that's the big problem
um
and you have a specificity of 95 which
means that
uh 100 negative patients 5 will come up
with a false positive
the outcome of that is even if you have
100 sensitivity
that um it's it's a little bit more
complicated mathematically but
uh what you would have is that from all
of these positive
tested people uh 50 are false positives
um and that that's that's a problem
because
everybody uh would say oh come on what
what is this for a test because
when you run the confirmatories on a pcr
test for example
uh 50 of these patients um turn out to
be negative
but you have guaranteed them you have uh
probably uh look for contact persons you
have put a guarantee in other contact
persons
um and you'll panic an awful lot of
people
and at the end people will say that the
tests are the rapid tests nuts
um and that's also something that needs
to be considered
yeah i'm just building on that uh class
obviously when you're looking at
trying to get you know the best test
will be
high sensitivity high specificity but
often it's a trade-off
isn't it when you're trying to get you
know
to get high sensitivity often you know
you have to give something on
specificity and vice versa
i think for the antigen test um
the the bias will be you know obviously
sensitivity and negative predictive
value
um you know it's not ideal having too
many false positives
but i think it's even worse um having
too many false
negatives um at least with the false
positives there may be a a
a way to introduce a confirmatory test
for those
but the false negatives you would never
know um and
to have someone walking around thinking
that they're they're not infected
when they are um uh could be uh would be
a much
much more uh difficult problem so i
think if if you if you have to
go one way or the other then for the
antigen test the bias should probably be
towards
uh sensitivity yeah ideally
higher levels but
yeah def definitely yes so in an
infectious disease test regardless what
we are talking about it doesn't
necessarily have to be
a zaskel v2 uh 19.
um in an infectious disease that's what
you're looking for as
as the best possible sensitivity because
you do not want to see any false
negatives
you will necessarily 100 sensitivity
since there will always be clinical
outliers that you simply will never find
regardless how good you do your your
clinical validation
um but the difference we have here is
in just opposite to any other
uh infectious disease that's that that
is on the market is we want to do a
screening test
and that makes specificity a bigger
hurdle than than usual
let's assume you look for a uh you do a
hepatitis b test
and you have reasons to do the hepatitis
b test
and if you have some if you have a 95
specificity um the few false positives
that you have
well the number will be much lower than
the real positives that you have in the
screening tests a 95
our specificity can easily bring you to
more false positives than right
positives
and and that that makes that that will
give you problems
um not necessarily on the market but you
will run a large number of
confirmatory tests that come back
negative and uh i said you will
you will create a lot of trouble with
the patients
uh was there was their environment their
personal environment
their work environment so you may shut
down
complete factories due to faults for
positive tests and
that's the worst case and that's
something we need to deal with
yeah okay i
you know we've got about five minutes
left and i think that i need to jump in
because you could probably spend another
half hour or so
you know probably longer it's still
going round with the team on the call so
maybe we can
you know cover some more in the
questions that come up from uh the
audience
but maybe as a way of you know closing
the call and summarizing
if we can go around each person maybe in
alphabetical order
so someone brendan this may be any
advice you could give to people looking
to develop these tests or what supports
available that you could help
advise them through to
well i mean there is a there's an
enormous amount of support available
you know so um particularly you know the
the us system is the one we know best
you know there's a lot of support in the
u.s system right now
uh coming from nih coming from bardo
coming from a variety of different areas
both from a funding from a networking
and from a technical perspective
um you know within the industry itself
um you know there's again there's a
there's a network of core providers that
have historically
existed within the lateral flow space uh
companies like ourselves
that are on this this call and i think
we we've historically
all had a a a culture
of of both promoting the best
possible practices within the latter
flow industry
and assisting companies coming into the
industry so there is quite a bit of
technical resource available from
the materials providers from the reagent
providers from companies like ourselves
that are contract developers and
educators and trainers and contract
manufacturers
so there is quite a bit of support
already out there inherent in the
industry
everybody is everybody is strapped from
a bandwidth perspective you know
everybody is busy right now
but at the same time we all recognize
that the importance of this
and i think as an industry one of the
one of the most heartening parts of this
for from my my own perspective has has
been watching the reaction to this
from the from the service and materials
and
equipment side of the business from the
people who really facilitate the the
development and manufacture of these
um the industry has really come together
in in quite an incredible way so
i think anybody anybody who touches
really any one of the core suppliers in
the industry is going to get network
very quickly into the other aspects of
what they need
so um you know we're we're here to
support both the
the companies that are that are newer to
the industry as well as
you know the more mature developers and
manufacturers
or that are you know just under pressure
with this whole thing to have to
develop products while validating them
while standing up new manufacturing
lines and new facilities while training
new people
um you know we're all here to to to help
as best we can
okay thank you and darren
uh yeah um just uh like
uh brendan's comments really around how
that network has all come together it's
uh really encouraging it's really
heartwarming
um you know i've been part of it for you
know 15 years in various
guys's uh through contract manufacturing
organizations to
now kind of heading up a test
development group ourselves um
you know and i found that that network
that i kind of got in touch with over
the years and built
um you know certainly kind of come to
fruition
in helping us deliver and you know this
test to market
as quickly as we've been able to um you
know
my advice to anybody kind of stepping
into this is
um a initially look at what's already in
the market
um you know to determine whether you
know is there is there an opportunity
here for me to compete
in that market with that test um albeit
that you know
we're going to be testing a covered you
know
sales call to a long long time
um you know you want to make sure that
you're in a position uh you know just to
make sure your business is
competing there and so once you've
identified which area you want to kind
of work into
get in contact with as many people as
you can within this network
be it um somebody like brendan at dcn to
help with that test development
uh with people like klaus um you know
and yourself uh you know
around those membrane suppliers and
we'll then certainly put you in touch
with all the other key suppliers for
materials
you know uh reach out to people like
myself and david who
supply some of some of the reagents into
it into the
network as well um yeah because you're
going to need that you're going to need
that support
um you know as well as the the end
manufacturers
and even regulatory and quality support
as well and one of the first things we
did when we started doing this
uh was reach out to the fda and get that
contact in there
understand what they needed uh as part
of this
and what they were gonna do and and they
held their hands up and they were like
we don't really know yet tell you what
let's work together and try and figure
this out
um you know which was great in one way
and it helped us
and you'll kind of steer our path in
that critical path but certainly
use the network this day um it's a it's
a fantastic and
heartwarming network that's accessible
to everybody and they'll
they'll embrace everybody with open arms
thank you darren it's uh really
insightful david anything to
add from your side well i mean i think
uh darren and brendan have pretty much
covered it but um i would just like to
add that uh that sort of
network and collaborative effort um
extends to the you know to the different
uh players
different companies in the industry
itself i you know i've been in the
industry for
many years as as we all have and i've
i've never experienced such a
collaborative effort
and putting aside some of some of the
normal competitive
uh issues um there's a collective effort
to get
these products to market um as quickly
as we can
so that's that's heartening i also think
the uh
uh what by going through this now
uh the industry is going to be more
pandemic ready next time because there
will be a next time
and there may be a next time for this
current pandemic um
but there will be another pandemic and i
think what we've gone through in terms
of
getting ourselves prepared to develop
products which will help tackle this
pandemic
will put us in a very good place um for
the
the next time it happens we'll be able
to respond much more quickly and i think
for the industry as a whole
um this has been uh it's an opportunity
for the industry to showcase
what we can do and what value our
products actually have
and because that i think has been
somewhat under the radar
uh from for for many many years and um
so those are i think those are those are
many of the positives so someone coming
into this
i think would um would find a
an awful lot of support for all the
different uh sectors that um
brendan and uh and darren have have said
including companies that they would
typically
see as their competitors okay
excellent thank you david close anything
briefly on your side because
we're about to reach a q a
so some some famous last words yeah i i
could bore you with
with another comment on networking and i
will definitely do that so
so what all of us have told you is
yes networking is key here uh we talk
about an unprecedented situation
about a pandemic that will
nobody will able to deal with that alone
so the advice is get out of your ivory
tower don't try
to reinvent the wheel on your own and
and talk to people talk to
to reach supplies to material suppliers
and uh work in in a network and that's
the only chance we have
uh to get uh this pandemic under control
to have
to have tests develop uh that really do
the job that we want them to do
um and to be prepared for yeah
um another pandemic um or the
reappearance
of uh sasko v2 because uh
if there's one thing that is sure it's
not over yet
and uh this virus will stay with us so
uh there there's enough work to do
okay excellent and um i guess that
brings us up to our q a
deadline so thank you everybody else i
think it's been you know excellent
really appreciate your insights and your
input and i'm sure the audience and
everyone joining this session will
you know echo that comment as well so
thank you very much and i think we'll
engine
hand over to our q a